welcome to the program those of you who
are watching will see I'm wearing my
John fetterman hoodie today uh John
fetterman did indeed win his Senate race
yesterday that is really good news and I
want to start with results from these
extraordinarily important 2022 midterms
I will not rehash all of the reasons why
these midterms are so important not the
least of which however it should be said
is trying to maintain a democracy in
which not just this year but in two
years in 2024 we can be confident that
the candidates who get the most votes
are accepted as the winners and assume
their offices without controversy and we
know that that almost didn't happen in
2020 expectations increasingly were for
an overwhelming red wave that would
devastate Democrats it didn't happen
it didn't happen we still don't know
it's still unclear big picture
who's going to end up controlling the
house uh Republicans have picked up
seats but as of right now we don't know
who will control the house
we don't know for sure who will control
the Senate but things are looking
increasingly okay there for Democrats
and some critical gubernatorial races
Maga can that it's failing miserably and
this result is a disaster for
Republicans now I know that there are
people tweeting me saying David
Republicans will probably still take the
house and then the Senate's going to be
split what do you mean it's a disaster
for Republicans historically Republicans
should have done really well and based
on all of the polling that Republicans
themselves were pointing to they were
saying this is going to be overwhelming
it's going to be open and shut
Republicans easily take the house with a
nice margin Republicans take the Senate
Republicans win all of the critical
gubernatorial races none of that is
happening none of that is happening
um Oz and mastriano lost
Tudor Dixon lost Herschel Walker
currently losing but probably heading
towards a runoff and we will see where
that goes Lauren bobert might lose
bobert an incumbent Maga Republican
Blake Masters down it will probably be
called today for his opponent Mark Kelly
Sarah Palin laughed away Kerry Lake we
don't yet know but she very well may
lose even though it increasingly was
being said oh Carrie Lake's gonna win
and if Republicans take the house it
will be by the smallest margin let's get
right into it starting with the Senate
who will control the Senate right now we
know
48.48 Republicans have so far not made
any pickups and Democrats have as of
right now made one pickup if we looked
at flipped seats that is indeed
Pennsylvania where John fetterman has
defeated television Dr Mehmet Oz with 94
percent of the vote in it is fetterman a
little over 50 Oz a little over 47 about
three points separating them that is a
really good result fetterman is a really
good candidate who suffered a stroke
some months ago struggled in a recent
debate
clearly not a cognitive issue if you've
seen in particular his speeches recently
if you see him right this is an auditory
processing issue and it seems that the
voters realize that now what's the
Counterpoint
quack TV Doctor Who has no business
being Senator almost won
right that you you can always find pros
and cons there uh if we go back to the
broader Senate map a critical race is
that in Georgia Raphael Warnock the
incumbent Democrat trying to beat off a
challenge from serial liar and
completely clueless barely able to speak
former football player Herschel Walker
there is What's called the 50 rule in
Georgia if neither candidate gets 50
percent there would be a runoff there
are three candidates and the Third Party
candidate Oliver has just over two
percent of the vote right now
Rafael Warnock is leading by half a
point which is 18 000 votes no matter
where this shakes out if it's Warnock by
half a point or Walker by half a point
it doesn't look as though either will
get to that 50 Mark meaning there will
be a runoff if that's the case we're all
going to Georgia and I don't know if I
will physically be going to Georgia I
may or we may try to figure out
digitally how to pour everything we can
Herschel Walker must not be allowed to
become a senator in the United States
it's horrifying other important races in
North Carolina it briefly looked like
Beasley might have a chance the Democrat
at defense at taking that seat from Ted
Bud ultimately it did go for Ted Bud it
was expected but there was a brief
glimmer of hope there in Ohio JD Vance
did defeat Tim Ryan that was expected
the polling was really pretty clear
there an extremely important race is
Arizona
it has not yet been called
it is starting to look like it will be I
want to be careful because news
continues to break Blake Masters may be
the worst person in the world
as an individual Walker is less
qualified but Blake Masters seems like a
genuinely worse person Mark Kelly the
incumbent right now leading by five
there is speculation it might be called
today only 69 percent of the vote is in
there a couple of other key races in the
state of Nevada Adam laxalt has taken
the lead against Cortez masto that's
disappointing and we are going to keep
an eye on that and in Wisconsin we still
don't know for sure but with 94 percent
of the vote in Ron Johnson the incumbent
is looking like he's going to be able to
Stave off a challenge from Mandela
Barnes a great guy who has been a guest
on this program six percent of the vote
remains to be counted and we can
maintain some amount of Hope there so in
the Senate right now completely
plausible that Democrats maintain
control we will know probably within a
couple of days looking now at
gubernatorial races again
not a disaster for Democrats with what
we know so far Democrats have made two
pickups in terms of Governors and
Republicans have made none important
races there of course Pennsylvania were
thankfully Josh Shapiro a great
candidate a genuinely great candidate
has easily defeated conspiracy theorist
Maga Trump riot
steal the election lunatic Doug
mastriano
this could decide the 2024 presidential
election the winner of this race which
is Josh Shapiro will decide who is the
Secretary of State in Pennsylvania and
that person will run the 2024 election
which could decide who is president of
the United States of critical importance
we're also looking very strongly at
Arizona
um Kerry Lake a complete cuckoo for Coco
Puffs conspiracy theorist who wanted to
secede who wants to end all abortion a
dangerous dangerous woman right now
she's down six tenths of a point
we have to wait we are hopeful
we are hopeful Carrie Lake will lose in
Georgia as expected Brian Kemp did
defeat Stacey Abrams that's too bad but
it was expected based on the polling in
Texas Beto O'Rourke lost badly to
incumbent Greg Abbott Beto O'Rourke's
political future is definitely in
question after yet another worse than
expected loss in Michigan fortunately
this is another loss for Maga Tudor
Dixon the Trump endorsed conspiracy
theorist lost by 10 to the incumbent
Democratic governor Gretchen Whitmer uh
wyom Wisconsin rather was briefly in
question but Evers defeated Michaels by
about three and a half points that's
really great news and we're still
waiting for results from Oregon
which if the Republican Drazen or drizan
I forget the pronunciation were to win
in Oregon it would be the first
Republican governor in decades right now
kotech the Democrat is ahead by one
only 76 of the vote has been counted and
lastly we have the House of
Representatives the House of
Representatives the most likely to go to
Republicans indeed Republicans have
currently made 10 pickups they need 17
more seats to take control it was
apparently a foregone conclusion it is
now not a foregone conclusion if they
win it will be a small margin one
interesting race hard to focus on a lot
of races here but if we do go to
Colorado and you go to the Third
District the Third District you will see
that Lauren bobert is losing by 1.2
Lauren bobert if she is defeated would
be the second big Maga cartoon to lose
this cycle Madison cawthorne losing his
primary after not even a full term
it's possible Lauren bobert will lose as
well 90 of the vote is in she's the
incumbent she's a Maga extremist and she
is currently down by 1.2 this all may
come down in terms of the Senate to
Georgia there is no Red Wave the Red
Wave is dead do not let anybody trick
you and I will even have clips of
Republicans admitting this momentarily
but the Red Wave is dead there may be a
ripple should have been a great midterm
for Republicans it'll end up being sort
of okay end of critical importance
Democratic Governors one in Pennsylvania
Michigan and Wisconsin
those three races this year could
determine who the next president of the
United States is and we'll have time to
talk about that as well I've had such
trouble finding a great razor where I am
not cutting myself or getting those
Nicks on my skin which are so common
with the cheap disposable razors you
have to meet our sponsor Henson shaving
Henson actually manufactures parts for
the International Space Station and the
Mars rover and they are bringing that
exact same Precision Engineering to the
Shaving experience it hurts when you
shave because blades extend too far and
thus they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below